this is a full match of 4v4 slayer halo
infinite
in our tech preview essentially the
version of this build
um on live fire so josh go ahead and
roll that when you're ready
yeah i think this is a it's a protein
pov
uh well let's see how good they are
right off the bat down for this you've
got the gateway right you've got to
switch the vert
it's good to have sites here back or we
call there's some nickname of statesy is
kind of the
the people implementing the vo they
threw down a shield covered the position
yeah i like that little peak technique i
haven't i haven't personally done that
to be honest
yeah i feel like i learned a lot by
watching this protein video actually and
how to play it like we watch them we
have
regular weekly play tests with them i
don't play with them generally because
they just
they're so good and we have we put our
kind of better players up against them
also notice that player went straight
for the power weapon that spawns on this
map in slayer which is
um hard for me to use if i'm being
honest
so you'll see like i mean so you can see
the front foe that's one of the obvious
things you're looking at here i know sam
was talking about it earlier
it's something that we've continued to
kind of iterate and evolve even beyond
this build
i think this all this might be our main
build right now
um there's power weapons spawns there
skewer is uh it's satisfying as heck but
it's hard for me to use i'm i am i am
worst at that gun than i am with the
commander rifle for sure when you hit a
target like especially a vehicle it's
super satisfying
all right so he was spectating
they missed the movie
hard for us to hear in studio but i i
believe there you're hearing some
personal ai coming through yeah you're
hearing there's a few things so we
there's the spartan chatter that we had
in halo 5 really just kind of brings the
battlefield gives a lot more like
reaction feedback on the game but you'll
hear this personal ai and what we did
with them is
we replaced what was called spartan
leader our team leader um
and they are it's just a more personal
version of that and they have a lot of
personality and so it lets you kind of
swap around and kind of
customize that feedback and they give
you a lot of low level they hold the
power up
yeah i was just gonna mention you know
that's a different a change right it
doesn't activate on pickup anymore you
can hold on to it
yeah we think that'll bring a lot uh in
the long term and allow us to do more
things with power-ups than kind of just
you know
traditional kind of just quick stack
kind of reflections but having like
really pop the notion of power equipment
in the game
one thing that we won't see from as in
this point of view i really love the
visual language that
you and the team have introduced it's
very obvious when someone's pocketing
a power up like that you'll see a
glowing trail there's like a contrail
behind them yeah that was a big thing is
making sure we at least telegraph that
information that was you know
making that switch there was a lot of
critical lenses on making sure that
there was at least a readability to it
in the gameplay i mean so now it's
sort of that risk reward right do i do i
hold this and wait for that final push
do i
burn it now so i don't lose it yeah you
make a lot of choices that way like
i sometimes will pocket it and think i'm
getting cocky and then i'll lose it and
i'll give like
overshadow that was a dope i'll get i'll
give the os to the
enemy which is you know super risky at
that point
we're seeing a couple of little sort of
what do we call those tutorial tips
popping up there which
you can turn off in this yeah you can
turn them off but on their death tips is
what we call them but yeah giving a
little bit of feedback you know
about the type of weapon that killed you
or like how you can respond better to it
i'm not sure at this point the pro team
needs to needs to know that like hey
yeah exactly like just opt out if you
don't really care about it if you don't
need that information or it makes you
feel bad
people might feel
i do love this map yeah the pelicans
flying by it's the you know it's
an homage to sergeant johnson sergeant
avery johnson the academy of
um so it's kind of cool just to kind of
pay homage to like you know
one of ours and everybody's favorite
character in the set of the halo canon
by the way
whoever this player is is just getting
getting active camo every spot
i don't know what the other team's up to
right now seems to be uh
watching that call out yeah we the
power-ups we treat those like you know
like the power weapons and stuff they're
up on a pad they have a lot of messaging
and broadcasting about them so you know
when they're coming up
yeah you're sparting the ai to tell you
that right yeah the spartan air calls it
out as well
there's a lot of information just kind
of driving feedback
and get the stick there
you can see like he'll look there's the
weapon radix you'll see in the levels as
well
he ran past one second
yeah right that's in the background
right yeah what's cool about them is
like you know before you might run
past where a weapon would spawn and then
not realize that it's coming up in two
seconds and it could change your choice
and like how you deal with it like when
we play tests this morning i actually
stopped at one point
on a wet rack because i was like oh it's
like two seconds out i might as well
wait for it and switch out my pistol
which i'm
i think i'm just telling everybody that
i'm really bad with a lot of the guns in
our game
i do love the sidekick and yeah i it's
really cool and like when somebody's
really good with it it's
really threatening because they can just
feather that thing super fast
this player really likes this little
like uh drop wall kind of
covering up yeah like kind of locking
down an entryway so they can watch their
back
it's neat to watch how people use these
like all the different equipments in
different ways
well hopefully a lot of players this
weekend are going to be uh lighting us
up on social sharing clips with us
because i can't wait to see just some of
the new creative ways that the community
at large
figures out how to use this new sandbox
yeah and it's interesting too like i
mean like the way we have our maps tuned
like in our main builds is they have
different equipment and stuff on them
and because we don't have the entire
sandbox and the flights as we swap
things out so it's actually not even the
same kind of
basically map placement path that we
would have in the the released version
of the game
but we you know it just at least gives
us something so we can get something in
there for people to play with
match is getting close you can hear the
music starting to kick up kind of
signifying the end of the match as well
i do i do love that the the multiplayer
music very cool
i'm really proud of the multiplayer
music there's a cool story about how we
got to
basically getting the music in the game
um but it really meets this tone
it's something i've really wanted since
halo 4 was this kind of post rock
soundtrack to the multiplayer
well actually just a halo it became one
of my goals for multiplayer
last kill
oh there we go cool
yeah that was actually me playing nicely
down nicely done
you